your topic you want me to set it up or
you good as far as the uh yeah you can
set it up all right Xbox raising prices
out in these streets Microsoft is hiking
the price of Game Pass and the series X
so this has come out shout out to The
Verge shout out to them the legendary
Tom Warren so I just paraphraged
paraphrase um series X price will remain
the same in the US and match PlayStation
5 pricing in most other markets game
pass prices are also going up in most
markets so you know they've alluded this
that Microsoft is increasing the series
X in most countries in August apart from
us Japan Chile Brazil and Colombia so
those kind of staying the same and that
um the also the Game Pass Game Pass and
Game Pass ultimate subscription for the
first time next month would you see a
base Game Pass description uh moving up
from 10 front to from 9.99 to 10 99 so
basically a dollar there and uh this was
kind of the communications yes
oh look at you I know what you're doing
um so this is from Carrie Perez the head
of Communications on Xbox we've held our
prices for consoles for many years and
have adjusted the prices to reflect the
competitive conditions in each market
and then the series X console going in
the uh moving in the UK from 400 479 uh
99 pound uh to 549.99 across most
European markets Canada from 649.99 and
um Australia I believe that's
799.99 in Australia starting August 1st
so um Series S pricing will not be
adjusted in any markets which is
interesting and um Game Pass ultimate
pricing that will increase will start
from uh July 6 and that will move from
the 14.99 to
16.99. so yeah those
yes King two dollars yes okay I'm just
I'm just you just try to clarify I need
to you know
like no they were coming at me hardcore
you wouldn't be yeah I have all the
summons I even have titus's Ultimate
Weapon and I try to score up for Lee uh
Lionheart so get off me get off because
there's anybody coming out here
everyone's everyone's level 100 but man
too and it's like I said I have all the
GFS all of them in eight Who coming in
why are you having to prove yourself
you're not the one that anybody's to be
coming out about finishing games
is I was I was I was making statements
about 16. and people didn't like that so
they're like
check your resume only hit you with the
resume yeah and what's funny is like
it's just like nah just just take that L
walk home because trust me it doesn't
end there I can bring up other Final
Fantasy we know how you get down bro
you're the attic for me they need to
walk away from him yeah that's not a
fight that's not a fight
young boy alone yeah yeah young boy
young boy's a shooter he will get you
out of there so he know life game
exactly yeah not that guy and in real
life he big don't mess with him
because I look small next time
oh my God you know what the first thing
they'd be there like yo I didn't realize
I'm big I'm beefy but this this tall boy
right there you say what you beefy all
right
moving on to the topic
get your beefy heads I like to eat I
like to eat at this stairs
he walked in the cookout
Vader like Cognito has entered the baby
[Laughter]
for body shaping me
he said yo when a guy describes himself
as beefy look out
Lord Metro with the two dollars
is ready you know oh man you're not
killing me right now is blood pudding
Moving On Moving On
Bessie
I'm gonna really get these people here
in the Attic let's go continue
oh no it's your topic
let's go so wait wait we jumped to price
raises and then we get into Indiana
Jones after right here but we
technically did Indiana shoots already
yeah okay everybody yeah
Thrice range I I actually think this is
a huge mistake on uh Xbox's part
especially with the momentum that they
had with that last showing look does
this kill all that momentum no but uh to
me it's like you know you finally got
some good publicity a lot of people are
talking about you in a positive light
you should have pushed this and you know
you determine that price to that series
X when you started your marketing for
this and you shouldn't have went back on
it I don't care what happens you don't
see too many companies ever doing this
just raising prices mid generation uh
this is this is not right and they
should feel ashamed of themselves but at
the same time
what what can I do yeah I I will say
that
it's the same thing I said with the
PlayStation
the people that aren't in America should
feel even worse because they literally
like the because in the majority of the
countries this was raised but America
and like maybe another a couple regions
like they literally just looked at
everyone else who said you know
we need the prices here to be
competitive with PlayStation and because
PlayStation raised the prices in these
other regions we could compete with them
by raising our prices and I don't think
that was the go you know being the 50
difference would have really helped you
in terms of you know once you start
getting these games out and I get it
starfield's coming out soon
so their mindset is this is probably
going to be the best game we've had for
a minute
and we're going to really try to
Captivate that but to me we just came
off redfall this is the time where you
lower prices not raise them this is the
time where you make more value to your
platform not make less value and raising
the cost of Game Pass made more sense
but that console is where I draw the
line that shouldn't have happened fair
enough addict has spoken saw with the
twisty face yeah chat about what's going
on son of a disagree with it with the
face
you know what it is it's just like
sometimes I really feel like humans
don't look at some of these like
scenarios and it's like it's just a
computer that they input numbers into be
like oh what should we do now it's like
like you know that you know that person
that we all know that like can't take a
compliment yes like when you compliment
them and they like insult you yeah they
can't take they can't they can't take a
w and just walk away
and it's just again it's not huge it's
not momentum shifting anything like that
it's just is an unnecessary mini rake to
step on right like why why do this yeah
don't don't do this especially again
listen The Game Pass increases we knew
were coming this is Starfield tax people
star field taxes
down the bangers are coming right the
bank isn't coming you're gonna get Forza
you can get star feel everything that
that's in the pipeline seems like it is
of that quality with this is not
Crackdown three we're talking we're not
talking about
this is Justified now especially I did
mine so I knew that was coming
did it you know they have announced this
prior or or maybe you'll wait a little
bit long sure but whatever the Game Pass
increases and those are across the board
so everybody paying the Starfield tax
right wait what's paying that so that's
fine but the console stuff is egregious
and it was it was egregious when meta
did it it was ingredients when
PlayStation did it and it's agree just
now when they're doing it uh you can't
it's it's hard to justify paying more
money I don't care what region you're in
for a piece of Hardware that is nearly
three years old it just doesn't make a
whole lot of sense it doesn't make any
sense it is the numbers will tell you
differently but at the same time you
cannot tell me that part for part some
parts of these not maybe not all but
some parts of these machines are now
cheaper to find and thus should be
cheaper to build right now I understand
inflation across the board is ridiculous
you have to sort of match but to me if
you're kind of quote called losing the
PlayStation in these other regions where
you're now matching them
it would behoove you to be below their
price point right it just makes sense so
in that regard the business reality
supersede sort of what the what what it
looks like right the the sort of uh
perception
so whatever man it's it's not a huge L
but It ultimately is an L I don't think
they needed to take right now you know
for me it just doesn't make a whole lot
of sense when it comes to the hardware
again the hardware that's the Big L
because for me no way no way you're
telling me to pay more money for
something now than at when it launched
nearly three years ago
how you feel it the game pass you knew
it was coming the timing is whatever but
it the game pass for me it is funny but
that is stuff okay
I'm sorry I'm I'm chat I'm done with it
I'm going out and I'm buying stuff for
this wall because I'm tired of people
saying this is the only fans angle and
what it is it's the white wall it's the
white wall that's what it is it's the
white wall we're done with that okay
this Banner's coming off and I'm putting
actual stuff back there because I'm done
with that that's like the eighth time
I've seen that what's funny is I because
I used to have uh like a portable like
my camera's on like a portable Mount and
I remember when people we're making fun
of it I put it beside my bed on purpose
and took a picture oh I was feeding
insane
maybe that's what it is I think maybe
they just want the bed pick oh
yeah because they heard that you sleep
with the door open yeah
time the door unlocked and the window oh
I remember that Super Chat moving on
moving on
I forgot about that suit I didn't need
to be reminded I didn't need that visual
movie okay beefy
okay
play the music play pictures
[Music]
[Laughter]
no doubt Lord King the nine BC version
how are we feeling the price I'm chunky
yesterday's price is not today's price
kick How You Gonna defend this right
defending it oh I'm not defending it at
all all y'all guys that was talking
about y'all got game pass for a dollar
give me that dollar back give me that
dollar back Beach y'all thought y'all
was getting away with it yeah man I got
game pass for a dollar it's up now give
me that dollar
all y'all campus yeah Game Pass is worth
a dollar I Gotta Give me that dollar
I don't like that yeah
um don't tell me is inflation it's
impossible because you're raising the
price of the X but not the S so you know
that makes your argument but they ask
you remember they did the right thing
with the S which is they give you a new
SKU so they can keep it at that price
and an older skill I wonder if they're
gonna discontinue they're going to
discontinue that one so you think you
think little man is out of there the
white I think the white man is out there
I think little white man is gone yeah
we're going to replace little white bear
little black man I think I think they
upgraded them and changed with the
bigger package
we're gonna have to change our little
man
right now our little man is not racially
sensitive you know what we should do we
should have little white man and little
black man and put them back
we don't have to do none of this
like this is
yeah
oh my god let's go all right so with the
hands down
he says it like do I lose it when he
says it like that I lose it continue
it's disgusting man
[Music]
Sony for doing it
um you think y'all not gonna get the
smoke real talk I could be fans of y'all
all I want
but wrong is wrong factual and you're
not doing it in in the sense that you're
doing it where there's no competition in
those markets that you're leading in
y'all raising the price
I said that the Sony Sony did that
the markets that they lead it in they
raised the price and do that over here
this competition here we need raising
the hair we're gonna keep that in this
in this States it's tough over here
hard out here
it's just y'all didn't need to do this
and if y'all really want to stand on
that square I know Starfield is coming I
know y'all fitting to have the best year
in a long time
and y'all had a great show I think
you're too high in your supply I think
somebody over there that decided to say
yo it looks uh wrong if our series X is
cheaper than a PlayStation 5 because it
makes it seem inferior Whoever has that
mindset over there and don't have the
mindset at sellout premium at a loss
under what they're selling it for so we
can gain more traction
that person needs to go oh damn because
financially
you're doing yourself a disservice so
you walk into the store listen y'all
still number three y'all ain't jump
overnight okay y'all walking somebody
walks in the store
and Playstation has their lineup up
there start filling out yeah bro and and
maybe that dude don't even know about
Starfield let's really think about it if
somebody goes in there and like yo we
got Starfield and this is the Casual
well they got Spider-Man
casual like I know who bought Spider-Man
he climb the walls issue the webs we'll
just star filter or you're going to
space and you got ships and you can
fight and you can make ships that sounds
like a Glock let me get that stuff
that's a Spiderman
y'all the same price
you got to give incentive you got to
give incentive to purchase you're not
that recognizable y'all keep acting like
you're famous you're not but what about
this let me let me let me be corporate
[__] for a bit go ahead so like what
about this King like all right
I like coffee
you're stupid
so like let's just say like all right to
your point right they shouldn't do that
whatever whatever but we heard right
part of the EU negotiations with ABK was
that they were concerned that once Call
of Duty coming to the service they got
haha now the price could keep going and
part of negotiation was to lock that
price in right at that time so now what
if they like yo if we don't do it now we
can't raise Game Pass or whatever ever
for the game pass like what do you feel
about that they try to beat it while the
before the finals is inevitable because
you're gonna have the family plan this
this is preemptive right you do this
have everybody have all this outrage oh
man they raising the prices at the
family plan
right it's the same thing they do
something else to mitigate the bad news
right they do because they're going to
take a loss with the family plan yeah so
let's lock in these single you know
player people like Sovereign
and then when we get the family plan and
iron Lords
it's different but
they do that now because they know
they're gonna take a loss with the
family plan let's just you know isolate
the the single players and and do that
um I just don't like it I don't like
anything that is anti-consuming this
smells anti-consumer to me uh nothing in
it uh screams that you know we're in the
biggest depression recession that we've
ever been in as a a country as as a
species for me at my time this is the
worst it's ever been and for you to just
say yo we're going to raise it up 50 I
already got my ex I already got my S
I'm fighting for the dude that didn't
the dude that was getting his pennies
trying to get it together so you walking
into the the room you you got your 500
left I got my five yeah it's fifty
dollars more
ah man no well we got a little man over
there that's the same price and we got a
little black man for fifty dollars it's
like yo it's just it's wrong it's not
right you shouldn't do it I'm not with
y'all on this and it's not about
inflation it's about actually inflating
your wallets they don't care about y'all
this shows that they don't care because
if you can you would say I'm not gonna
raise it raise game pass because I
thought Game Pass was always the
greatest value at the cheapest price is
what the best deals right so yeah a
dollar two dollars yeah it's it's it's
it's really not about the the the small
amount that is being raised y'all gonna
get that dollar back I always knew that
he was gonna get that dollar back I
always knew that they would it's not
giving you nothing for free nobody do
right once they lock you into those
numbers stabilize once they saw those
numbers yeah okay we got 30 million and
stable same 30 million we had last month
same 30 me get our dollar back
you like it they like it they like it
back so
what do you feel about the argument
that's saying but addicts they aren't
raising PC game pass they're only
raising console games because there's
competition over there I was going to
touch that too it's competition over
their attic anywhere that is real
competition at they not raising the
price but where there's no competition
and they're probably dominating in that
sector or they they're close to being
like number one if not number two
they're gonna raise the price because
they can it's just doing something
because you can
is there competition because there's
multiple storefront those are
competition because there's multiple
subscription models because I would
argue that
storefronts a little bit more of an
argument over there on PC but the
subscription model the majority of those
subscription models are on consoles as
well right so it's just like it are they
seeing more of a growth on PC or are
they seeing you know there's more people
on on Xbox currently and they're trying
to milk those and then eventually
they'll milk the app that goes into a
bigger argument as The Wider PC dudes
don't have to pay for uh Xbox Live
that's why I bring that up because we
got to the point where it's not only
do they not have to pay for PC online
they don't have to do anything for to
access the internet well we shouldn't
have to right but they're also not
getting increases on on subscriptions
that console owners are getting caught
they're getting their raise and remember
there was a time because it was in beta
you paid half yeah for the PC game pass
when they didn't do that on Console when
they were starting that up but the thing
is that that is an open market PC is an
open market Xbox console is an isolated
uh situation so they know when you go
buy an Xbox you're locked in you have no
other choice but when you buy a PC you
have so many options to do so many
different things let's just get them in
any way we can I think to me
business-wise I can understand why they
do it but as a consumer
uh it's like look if if you feel like
you're still growing the audience on PC
you wait till you feel comfortable
raising on both you don't just raise it
on one and keep it on the other like I
don't like that I'm gonna be real with
you I don't like that I feel like that
is another example that could be used
against that uh against the narrative
that they treat console own owners like
second-class citizens compared to PC on
PC you are placed on PC you have PC
exclusive content over there that's true
you you have you don't have to pay for
gold you don't get right you don't get
raises on PC Gamepad you can make a huge
credible argument that they are pushing
you into the PC market well I mean I
believe everybody's going that way
anyway I believe the PlayStation's going
that way I believe Xbox is going that
way Nintendo probably won't but I
believe that's where they will
ultimately end up that PC is the
ultimate um It's The End Game
I believe that's it I believe
everybody's going to be an app
I I just believe you're going to grab
your controller and play where you want
to play how you want to play it and um
if you have a dongle or if your TV
supports it if you're the tablet
supports it I just believe both of them
is going to get there who gets there
first depends on this APK deal because
ABK deal goes through it's only gonna be
the first app
Eastwood in the chat Xbox need to get
rid of gold ASAP yeah they got to figure
that part out that's later yeah because
it's just one of those things where it's
like look like does it bother me
specifically no I don't really care to
be honest it bothers the hell out of me
but I understand why people get upset
over it and it's frustrating because the
biggest thing that bothers me is if a
game can function on Console it just
takes a little bit more time like gears
tactics or um uh the Age of Empire games
because those eventually did come to the
console Market you hold that to you can
release simultaneously on all your
platforms you don't do it over there
because you want to appeal to that
audience if you wanted to put that
audience you would keep it just on that
audience but clearly you have the
intentions on bringing it over here
eventually don't do this really see over
a little bit because then it makes me
think that's a that's a window I can
open okay now we're gonna have mobile
games on like it's just like so now
there's mobile games only and PC games
only but no console games only and it
just sits wrong with me as because I
don't play on PC like that but it it
does put a bitter taste in my mouth
that's like why is everyone getting
everything but the console manufacturers
uh that the people that go out there and
we invest more if you want to get
technical we go out and spend the 500 on
the platform so we debate the testers
yeah you can make an argument that we
are we baby boy baby boy we
we try everything first and the biggest
reason I'm like being very vocal about
this because I know a lot of Xbox people
watch this and it's just like
when is it when's the line because I
personally feel like we've crossed the
line
oh my God because to me it's like
where's the line because I personally
feel like we have crossed the line you
know we holding it
[Music]
yeah I'm fantastic yeah now look um I'm
with y'all like no one should be
cheering on price hikes so it should be
pumping a fists like yes this is what it
is you know even if even if our Market
is unaffected right in the US so to
speak as far as the um the console but
um look you know we got it we got to
give you know what's the same energy as
the kid saying You got to get the same
energy you know we gave PlayStation that
energy when they did it we didn't really
care for that and you know usually like
soft said as the generation goes on from
a console perspective you think they
figure out ways to bring price and cost
down consoles get smaller you eventually
get you know cheaper skus and you know
it doesn't seem to be the case here I'm
with King though the game passing
doesn't bother me as much because I've
always felt like they've hinted you know
this kids can't stay at this price
forever you know we can't stay at this
price for right now like they've been
saying they've been throwing you the tea
leaves
um with King though also or like I find
it absolutely hilarious that they have a
bomb show Xbox got gays ah they got
games you like you like this is like a
controlled we're stepping on a rake time
yeah like it's like we're gonna
intentionally step on the rake but it's
just like the timing of me is just I
knew it was gonna happen the question
was when and I understand though
corporate [__] understands because I
knew they gotta do it now because we we
still off the Euphoria of how great
things are right and before the decision
on the ABK deal is done because if it's
done I feel there's a strong chance you
won't be able to raise prices for a
while because the FTC said man all that
stuff they're looking at that to see if
you are doing nefarious things what's
Call of Duty is in your service and in
your control what I find very
interesting is the series s not moving
on price so I like look at it is like
okay that's still what they view as
their entry point to get a person
because I think they have data right so
I'll wear 50 more than 50 percent of
people who are new to the Xbox ecosystem
bought a series s exactly so that to me
is still the entry point I am very
curious though if little
white back
stays around yeah because if remember
Starfield
you saw it was 130 something gigs or
whatever it is right gonna have season
passes that's from what we see this is
the game that people like yo I am
looking to get an Xbox yeah so if they
come through on you know this on series
that's low man you know what I mean like
that's gonna be interesting you're gonna
need more hard drives because you got
Starfield you wanna you're gonna have
Game Pass and you're gonna be able to
download three games how much OS is
actually taking up that's left like 300
you left with 320 something 300
something and you know we haven't talked
about it real quick well let me
interrupt you we just hit 17 000 so oh
shout out to the people that hitting
that sub button salute salute yes we we
do owe you guys the console giveaway yes
uh somehow we hit 2 000 after the
console giveaway in a matter of a month
facts we had we had 15 000 a month ago
so look you know I'm very curious to see
if it stays around now this you know um
little black man comes around yeah
technically stay around but you
mysteriously won't be able to find it
but another thing to think about is that
Western Digital just released their
versions of the SD cards that are much
cheaper than the other ones right so now
the idea of getting an OG little white
mix that's great the fact that we got
these names is out of pocket yeah I
gotta use it it's it's more feasible now
because before we the argument could be
made just get a serious X at that point
right because these things are so
expensive
um but now I think though the Western
Digital cars are much cheaper for at
least the one terabyte so you can get
that and not break the bank and maybe
maybe be close to what you might pay for
the for the the black one terabyte
little man so
um yeah it was it was it'll stay around
oh gee little white man yo they stupid
what did you call them
I'm leaving that a little just a little
bit there we go little black man
but the thing that I also find
interesting that's my last point is that
um you know as far as the Game Pass PC
game pass being unaffected